did you know that zenitsu has a demon
brother kaigaku is a former Demon Slayer
who replaced daki and guitaro as upper
Moon six after they died but while he
was still a Demon Slayer kaigaku trained
under the same Master as zenitsu the
former thunder hashira jigoro kuwajima
in fact gigoro treated both of his
disciples as his own children and he
wanted them both to be equal and to see
each other as brothers he wanted both of
them to be his successors but kayaku
hated zenitsu because he thought that
zenitsu was weak and he started
resenting his own Master for acting like
zenitsu and kaigaku were equal while
training to become a hashira kayak who
came face to face with upper Moon one
kokushibo kaigaku sensed that the upper
moon was way stronger than him so he
surrendered and begged kokushibo to turn
him into a demon subscribe to anime
uproar for more Demon Slayer videos oh
and